all right now to your viewer responses  and mail tonight on a lighter note you  might remember from watching last night  we had an uninvited guest on the show  bug who became famous infamous even for  calling on my jacket and collar but I  even feel it in my neck which obviously  set off a firestorm of reactions one  viewer wrote in well it looked like a  stink bug on you making its Fox News  debut needs a tiny Magga hat all right  very well said and on a different note  Laureen says the President's veto  earlier today he will veto the vote they  don't have the 2/3 votes to override  President Trump wins couldn't agree more  strong points the wall will go up